and
um
before we start uh if representative
soucy could lead us in the pledge to the
flag
to the flag of the united states of
america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you very much
and we have five bills
um in executive session today
uh with
will out of the room we've got two that
i think will go more quickly and easily
so i will take those
and hopefully he'll be back to handle
some of the harder issues
so
first up hb
i will open the executive session on hb
1352 this is the one relative to workers
compensation
for an adverse reaction to mandatory
covid vaccinations
and i will recognize
representative oh i was going to make
this motion right and i think
uh
so it is
made and seconded do you want to speak i
can
since i was planning on saying something
i i i could
all right
so this is a bill that we we heard in
public testimony essentially would
reproduce in rsa
what is already the policy of the
department of labor
under um
under more more general uh guidance from
the rsas
so from that standpoint i
the language of this bill
would be redundant and not necessary and
so with the agreement of the sponsor
representative huff
also on the committee um
we are asking that it simply be itled
is there any further discussion
representative sullivan
like he said
all right let me just make sure i
get this filled out any further
discussion
before we move to a vote
seeing none uh mr clerk if you will call
the role seaworth
yes
avalani
callum
yes
myself yes
love yes
warden yes
turcotte
yes
pro yes
boyd
not here
huff
yes
sullivan yes
susie yes baruti yes
cahill yes
outshiller
yes
bartlett
toomey
bouchard yes
adjutant yes
minimal yes
again so 19-0
unanimous
who's here
any objection to consent calendar
seeing none
it will be so
so
the reason i don't get the big bucks is
because i i don't quite know how to to
do this properly and i neglected mr
clerk
um to take a
a roll call of the committee when we
opened the session
which you did by taking that vote uh do
do we have a for uh
i think we should do a formal roll call
for who is president okay i can do
another roll call
infantine
no
seaworth
here
avalani
callum president
myself present love
warden morning
turcotte here
pro here
void no
huff
here
sullivan
yup
susie
rudy here
cahill here
outro or subbing for the silvestro
yes sir
uh bartlett subbing for schmidt yes
toomey
bouchard here
excellent here minimal here
okay now official
thank you very much um
i i can see on the next bill a
representative is preparing a statement
and i i know he wants a little more time
to
finish it
and so i want to
kind of jump ahead
one of the bills that we
have before us has to do with the
insurance and the family leave plan
that was passed in this year's budget
and i have been informed that the
insurance commissioner
is available in the room
uh today he was he did not speak at our
public hearing
and
um therefore has made himself available
today
if you have a
statement
that you can make and and be able to
answer some questions on that i think
that would be helpful to the committee
there
that would be helpful to our committee
when we do uh vote on that bill
thank you uh my name is chris
nicholopoulos and i'm commissioner of
insurance and it's so nice to be back at
the state house uh
you know it's been two years
of of covid hayes and it's nice to be
back here um
the department of insurance is really
excited about the family medical leave
proposal that was included in the budget
and our team along with several other
state departments has been working
really hard
to get that rfp ready and out
uh i think the the bill that came that
came out of the budget was a phenomenal
compromise and really is the new
hampshire way
to address a nationwide
desire to deal with family medical leave
availability we've seen a number of
states pass
state mandated programs
mandated on everyone we here in new
hampshire i think twice passed an income
tax to fund a family medical aid program
and this this program that was developed
is a voluntary program available to
everyone
in part uh kicked off by the 10 000
employees of state government
and
will make both individual plans
available and group market plans
available
in a time where
that coverage
didn't otherwise exist a private market
insurance company offering a full family
medical leave product um
didn't exist when this bill passed and
in fact we've had our first filing for
what will be a competing product a
family medical leave product filed by
nationwide this last year it is not
unfortunately it is not the same product
it is not uh does not provide first
person coverage is a group only product
isn't any there's not an individual
solution
um there's no tap in fact there's no uh
tax credit either um
and we're at a critical time the rp will
be going out soon
i'm hopeful that many companies will bid
on this product and i think the this
innovative solution
to a nationwide desire
is
something that we should support
thank you
a question you mentioned
the nationwide plan and some of the
things that doesn't have first-person
coverage there were some other terms
that
us not being familiar with insurance
maybe you could explain it in more
detail so first person coverages is for
the employee and so the nationwide
product is a family support uh product
and so that if you needed to to be at a
doctor's appointment or cancer treatment
with your kids you would have a coverage
for that but if you needed it for
yourself it would not be wage
replacement for that and so that's when
i talk about first person coverage and
is obviously a critical part
to it so it's it's kind of half of the
sandwich the you know the family support
part but not the not the first person
coverage
uh when i talk about group i mean this
product will be marketed to employers to
provide to their to their staff but
would not be available to
a single person looking to have it for
themselves and their family
um
and so that's that's the difference it's
a huge distinction
thank you uh representative pro
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
so you said that the the product that
you've seen started to come out doesn't
have first person coverage is that
because that would really be the
territory of short-term disability in
that type of insurance that already
exists for a lot of people
um
wonderful question representative in
part the answer to that is yes the
simple answer is yes if you
uh if you combined a short term policy
and a family medical leave policy that
excluded first-person coverage uh
possibly you could kind of have an
amalgamation of different policies that
made that coverage
when that happens when you try to put
together lots of parts what you end up
with unfortunately is
inefficiency you're managing two
policies for the potential same loss and
you also potentially end up with
different definitions
of what uh what
what a serious medical condition could
be
um you could end up with different
requirements regarding a coordination of
benefits which is
part of
kind of this policy development is how
you coordinate benefits
do you require an eligible employee to
use their second vacation time first do
you require them in fact to use a
short-term product that might be
available to you
and so
it could be achieved but it is not a
seamless one solution pick up one policy
and know what you have for coverage
um thank you for the answer um does
nationwide offer short-term disability
and is do you think they're trying to
design this as two policies that they
both offer for a company to kind of
choose a la carte and make a
a nice looking
uh benefits package for employees is
that something that you can see
happening is two policies from the same
company meshing better
um
nation first question yes they offer a
variety of policies including certain
coverage
whether or not
they're looking at it as a a cart
thing it's just too early to tell
what that will look like
and even with that because those
products are approved separately the
forms are approved separately the
underwriting will be different the teams
that that kind of manage each type of
policy each type of claim are different
um and so i do expect that once this
product gets off the ground that we may
see
comprehensive solutions that compete
with the state product i hope that we'll
see that
i expect that we'll see that
but i think creating
this model model that we're we're in the
middle of creating and finalizing
is going to be the impetus for um
fully providing
what we think of as kind of the minimum
level of coverage with all the
flexibility to add on
so that these
whether you're the selected um
successful uh provider for this this
product or you're a competitor you're
going to have the flexibility to add on
more than the minimum um
but i think
this is going to be a phenomenal
catalyst and we're starting to get calls
from around the nation because this is
this isn't the appropriate approach
thank you uh representative bartlett
please
thanks very much mr chair
welcome commissioner um i just want to
make clear that you are speaking in
opposition to this bill is that correct
i guess i'm speaking i'm hoping very
much that you don't ought to pass a bill
to unwind this critical program right
before we go out to rmp thank you for
the clarity um i think
representative sullivan followed by
representative manneville
thank you for taking my question um
first of all i believe any family paid
family medical leave is better than no
paid family medical leave um but that
said um
how concerned are you about um adverse
election when
especially with regard to the
individuals who choose um
to take it or not to take it um i can
see how um the the group coverage where
an entire company covers all their
employees
wouldn't involve adverse selection but
if i'm out there independent and i
decide to take it
isn't that a risk
100 percent it's a risk when you have an
individual product that people can opt
in one at a time
that that group may be more likely to
take a claim
than uh than a group
you know somebody who seeks out this
coverage for themselves themself
probably has a reason to do that
maybe they're in the child-rearing years
maybe they're worried about
care for
some one of their family members
and i think the critical part of why
this program
is viable and why i believe
several companies will bid on the rp is
because using the three pots the three
groups that are going to be covered here
the state employees as kind of the
kickoff start
the group policies that people can sign
up for
and the individual policy is going to
allow a company to offer to kind of
bake in
in their under in their rating
for all three and in time as this as the
years go on you know three four five
years in we're gonna figure that out
we're gonna figure out um
if if there is adverse selection
um
and also i think we're also gonna figure
out you know two three years in
um because we've heard for five years
now how critical this coverage is
people want it
and once we get this program off the
ground we're gonna see
if if they're willing to actually get it
and and how it works uh i i suspect um
as do the experts in my office that it
is going to be embraced
um but uh and
i also agree with the position that
uh something is better than nothing i
think having a tool a comprehensive
product that's available to consumers to
buy is better than where we are
today which
isn't available
representative mandeville thank you uh
thank you commissioner
um
as i understand it i'm new to this
process uh you have an rfp out
relative to the plan
um my question is
what is the
time frames
for the rfp in terms of its start and
close time
and what in general terms will the
department's criteria be
in analyzing the responses
including any sort of material
qualifications for
a potential acceptance of one of the
proposals i should also ask too is it
uh the department that will make the
final decision among the plans proposed
perfect uh so i'm glad you asked that
question because i think it's important
that we clarify that the rfp is not
coming out from the insurance department
but it's coming up from department
administrative services
now administrative services is working
with
five four or five state departments to
figure this out
and so there will be a panel
of experts to help
uh score the policies uh there are a
couple of there are
irrespective of the scoring there are
safeguards and one of the primary
safeguards is ultimately that my
department approves
the company the company who wants to
sell this product needs to be a licensed
and a viable company in new hampshire
which means we've we've
we've
investigated and approved their finances
and their their structure
the form the form of each policy will
need to be approved by my team the team
of department that reuse forms
and in preparation for that the
department has
worked on our rules that will kind of
govern what the forum and policies will
look like that's been sent out to uh to
industry groups for feedback
the rfp is going out soon i don't know
the exact date
31st before the 31st
and then it'll be several weeks and
we'll get back and and the people will
rate it
i hope that's enough of an answer
uh if if i may follow up just quickly
will one of the
uh criteria be
a
rating a company rating and if so
from whom and what
it will i don't believe the rfp requires
a rating though i've
not verified that stat to be to be a
licensed new hampshire authorized either
domestic or foreign insurance company
generally that requires a a minus rating
with uh with bests it now that's not the
same for every company there are comp
there are smaller companies that don't
have a best rating that have a a minus
rated parent and through some guarantees
we do that but but yes
further questions representative avaloni
thank you mr chairman thank you
commissioner for being here today uh can
you define what a group is
uh a group is a employer group
simply um
so maybe an employer
as an employer how many employees would
you need to be part of the employer
group
two
does that include
does that include the owner and
employees or is it technically employees
would it be a 40-hour
you know
minimum
i
there are a lot of experts drafting the
definitions i believe it would be any
two employees whether they're owners or
not
could be a group okay and one can you
tell me how this is funded
uh
primarily
it it's funded through the the premiums
that will be charged um now i say that
but there are a lot of factors here
there's a factor um of which the startup
cost to kind of get the rfp going and
get the experts supporting the state i
was funded by general fund
um
there is a
bt tax
credit to offset some of the employers
portion that they pay
so that's funded and ultimately 10 000
state employees will be covered under
this product and that will be a benefit
to state employees
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
commissioner for being here uh follow up
on uh representative avalani's um the
ten
thousand five hundred eleven thousand
state employees that are going to be
covered how is that funded whose pays
for that uh
the state the state will be paying for
that under the from the employees
benefits line item um and that that
group
um because because of the draft of the
bill that passed uh the state employees
don't have first person coverage and
that's because the state benefit package
is such that they already have that
coverage
and so the state group
should be
cheaper ultimately we'll see when the rp
comes out but it should be cheaper than
uh than the traditional products that
will be on the sides of it
um but that will you know for my
department it will be funded from our
administrative assessment
through uh staff salaries i
it should not
i guess a lot of money is is it depends
on who's saying those words but
should not be allowed
so in effect you're saying that uh the
taxpayers would be actually funding
indirectly the cost of the state
employees
yeah like all state benefits
well in my in my case the department is
funded with administrative assessment on
insurance companies
but who pays for insurance companies i
guess the insureds and those are
taxpayers
follow
for the state employees that are covered
by collective bargaining agreements
would that require bargaining it does
not it does not thank you
follow it
um
there were two bills this year
to remove fmli
one in this committee and one in
commerce
i was in this one when it was presented
and i was also
testified in the commerce committee
i'm curious as to why nobody from your
department was at either one of those
public hearings and why at the last
minute
we are hearing from you now thank you uh
i i apologize that i wasn't uh here i i
in fact for your committee meeting i was
traveling out of state
um
i
wrongfully assumed
i wrongfully assumed that other people
who were interested would be here to say
all these things
and when i heard they weren't i
made the offer to
uh to both chairmen that i would make
myself available um
i think it's clear today i'm passionate
about this proposal i think
as a regulator i want this product to
succeed because i want this product to
be available to new hampshire consumers
i'll take the responsibility for that
i'm sorry
other questions
representative prout
thank you mr chairman thank you
commissioner for taking my question
following up on your answer to
representative turcotte you said that
the benefit available to state employees
doesn't include first-person coverage
is that unique to the coverage for state
employees do we have two different
products being bid on one for state
employees and a
separate distinct product
for everyone else
could you explain that a little bit more
it is
it ultimately won
the r1rp and one bidder who will provide
three kind of
three buckets of coverages
almost the exact exact same
there's the individual pool
the state pool and the group pool
the state pool
because we know
we know exactly what their coverages are
and their benefits we were able to
exclude the first person coverage
because
because we're in charge of that we're
able to mesh those exactly
and we're drafting the rfp around that
and so it was
unnecessary to
to provide first-person coverage where
they already had it and so that was
carved out of the state employees
was that the only question or did i miss
the second one
um i guess my question was if a
employer a non-state employer already
has first-person coverage either through
an insurance contract they're happy with
if they've chosen to self-insured and
you know through other
benefits
would they
have the option of getting a plan
similar to the state plan is or is their
only option
terminating their existing self uh short
term disability benefit and going with
the whole package if they want to
participate in this
i believe the answer to that question is
if they want to participate
in a product provided under this
program
they would they would get the first
person coverage within this program
now that does it because this is an
option and no employer is required to
get this
they they could kind of build that
policy at least to some extent with the
nationwide and the short-term disability
um because it's not as efficient to do
that and because the tax credit
available to these businesses is
available for the state approved product
i don't think that's going to be the
case
i think that
until until the marketplace has
developed sufficiently that
all of the unknowns all of the adverse
selection unknowns are are known
um
that it'll be hard to compete with the
state profit
um thank you uh
so
just to clarify one thing you said if
they try to build their own product to
keep their existing short-term
disability assuming they had it they
wouldn't be eligible for the tax credits
that were in
what was passed in the budget
if they
adopt if michael if i'm understanding
your question you're asking if they did
if they adopted to find fmli
coverage um family coverage outside of
the approved product
um
they would not they would not be able
thank you
i'll recognize representative schiller
and then representative avaloni
thank you very much um thank you very
much for being here commissioner and
i would like to dial back to a statement
you made a few
answers ago
for clarification because i i don't
think i
i don't think i heard you correctly um i
just want to clarify
are you
stating that state employees coverage
you had said will be paid by the state
because it's my understanding that state
employees
will be paying for this coverage
themselves we're not
that is not a state benefit that is a
benefit offered to the employees
to pay for themselves
is that
i want to clarify
or the department that yeah working for
it will not be charged to the employees
thank you
all right
representative babalani
thank you mr chairman
um thank you commissioner again um why
only one company for this product
um
good question it's a complex it's a it's
a complicated
uh
product that we're building with the
three parts um
and
and the kind of the wild card
is what potential adverse selection they
will be in the individual market place
and that is offset by the state
employees in the group
um
and
we're confident that insurance companies
are sophisticated enough to figure that
out to make assumptions on on those risk
profiles given that it is it is a
limited benefit it's six weeks sixty
percent um
and
one having one company be able to to do
that
for the for the whole product uh
initially is i think the best way to
ensure that you don't end up with
somebody having a product that is gets
all the adverse selection and somebody
who doesn't
um
because it will be a guaranteed issue
for those individuals
thank you mr chairman
the
one company solution
other states
um i've worked in this bill several
times over the last two three or four
times
um
several other states have had a public
private partnership and they've offered
it through multiple companies have you
looked at their products or companies
and invited them in before
this bill came to be i mean it's been a
number of years we've been discussing
this and why hasn't a private option or
forgive me your office put this product
out to
open
open open the doors to other companies
uh so
first off
i've followed this to
through the processes of of the two
income tax bills
i was not commissioner then and in fact
the the bill that most of this language
came from was drafted before i was at
the department i know they did an rfi
before that
um
to be honest with you i'm i'm not aware
of a state that has a
a
private public partnership
that issue that includes mandatory uh
coverage for individuals
an option for employers uh including the
state
uh i i believe we are blazing the path
for this solution i don't think somebody
else has that solution
um new york has a private option um have
you looked at their model
new york i thought new york had a
mandatory option
um
and that's different
you know everybody has to have it but
you could get it from if you don't take
our program you get it from the
private market is different
from
we make it available to everybody to
elect to have it
why haven't we done that to this point
and made it not it made it optional for
employees to buy into a program instead
of being mandated in other states being
on the hook to pay for this for a
certain segment of the population and
then have
a one company come in and draw the line
for everybody else
if your question is why aren't we
mandating that every employer buy this
coverage
yeah i think that's what this program is
this program is exactly that
it is
other than the state employees that the
state is deciding the option
uh everybody else is optional we're
creating we're creating a mechanism for
a company to produce exactly what we
want which is a product that covers
family medical leave here in new
hampshire
that is entirely optional other than the
state employees but which
you all decided to put in the budget so
it is 100 optional
follow-up mr chairman it'll be my final
one
um right optional so why hasn't it been
done prior to this bill coming out
we've heard this for at least the last
10 years for fmli or a product that
would cover employers
employees i mean everybody has been
claiming for some for some option of
this and why hasn't been done to this
point
why isn't there an optional family
medical leave coverage that any
individual or group
could get
correct
because of adverse selection because if
you cr if you create if you insurance
company created a product and now
understand that ours also has a cap in
it to ensure that the rates are uh
obtainable for those individual market
participants
um
you know a company doesn't know that
they're
not only going to get
the people who are going to take the
benefit
and obviously it's a much more expensive
product
um if you only get adverse selection
one more
thank you i completely understand the
adverse selection but competition breeds
savings for
customers yeah and
this product will i believe will have
competition
um i've had an opportunity to talk to a
number of companies that they could be
in this space on their own already
at some level and they're not good not
no one is going to adopt the individual
option plan
yet but uh that are talking about me
making a competing plan
or the ability to have a competing plan
if they either don't bid or aren't the
successful bidder and i think there will
be a lot of copycat plans
i hope there'll be a lot of copycat
plans
uh first representative cahill and then
representative prout thank you mr chair
and thank you commissioner getting back
to mr pratt's question about an employer
who already has short-term disability if
they
if they took the state plan as well or
sorry the group plan from the state
would it be a situation where there
would be a primary and a secondary
insurer for a claim
probably not and probably not because
um because our short-term policy and
this product
are the same coverage
what you will see
is employers who
either add endorsements to the state
plan to have potentially more weeks of
coverage or maybe even a higher weekly
return in the you know in the in the
group market uh but what we'll likely
see is that plenty of companies will
still opt for long-term coverage which
will be the extension after some period
thank you
representative pratt
thank you mr chairman thank you
commissioner um
you said a moment ago in your answer
that uh you thought there would be
competition uh in the marketplace in
coming after this
um we've heard about a little bit about
the tax cuts now they're only available
to the winner of the state rfp
can you quantify in terms of what
percentage off the price you expect
those tax cuts to represent and
how you think there will be competition
from other companies
with a company that
does get that
um lower starting baseline because of
the tax credits and how other companies
could compete with that
in a i
assume as a low margin environment um so
i think the tax credit's 50
so that the answer is 50
um and
but what that's not taking into account
for is
at least initially
the unknowns of adverse election or
or claims usage
it may not be the best you know until
until it develops until
insurance companies know how to kind of
anticipate claims over a long period of
time
um
it may
and you're offsetting some of the group
payers with individual markets that they
must issue
um i think
it it
may be that a competitor could offer a
product or a
a cadillac version of it that has a lot
more coverages
or broader even broader definitions of
family or even
so i think the insurance companies are
innovative and they'll look at trying to
set themselves apart
thank you
representative you had a question
thank you mr chairman uh thanks again
for taking uh hopefully a couple
questions here uh one comment and
we've been talking a lot about what
adverse selection and
that sort of
opting in
i too have been involved with several of
these fmli uh in labor committee and the
last one that i was involved with was
the
one put forward by senator feltus and in
that one that was a going to be a
mandatory for everybody
as that
process progressed
that was not found to be a very
popular plan
and then
individuals started looking at an opt-in
program which made it
extremely
impossible
to go and the reason why is
just as you mentioned you brought up the
example of the individual and it was
always the easy one to to utilize
because it was a time frame and that was
somebody who knew they were going to
become pregnant
and we determined back then that
somebody could put in as little as a
couple hundred dollars in
in uh premiums and take out several
thousand
um so what happens is when you go to an
opt-in program like that you what ends
up happening is it it collapses or
becomes so prohibitively expensive
that nobody
nobody does it
the question i have uh next would be
that was my statement this the question
would be
have we qua have you quantified the 50
tax credit that this would give to
employers what what the total loss of
income tax
revenue would be on that i have not
i don't know
right yeah
follow up
and i think
the difference
because you mentioned the the feltes
plan which is i think the last one that
passed the legislature that was a half a
percent income tax
uh or a fee
half a percent on wages
for a product that was mandatory for
everyone i believe the last version that
was 12 weeks of benefits
and and the state was on the state was
the insurance company in that in that
method and so that meant
if something like you know imagine
if the uh the feltest plan
that we we last was last vetoed had
passed and something like covid19 hit
the warhold
there potentially would have been lots
of of claims for
in that period that we wouldn't have
anticipated and the state was the
insurance company and i think my fear at
that point was the state is not in the
business
of
uh of setting rates for its own product
and certainly
with all the restricted legislature i
don't think deciding that a half a
percent income tax and this benefit is
going to be enough was prudent
and using a private insurance company a
a viable private insurance company who
can do that and will take the upside and
downside risk
to me that's the new hampshire way
follow-up
when you say we would take the upside
and downside risk are you talking about
taxpayers or uh i'm saying that
this plan that's in front of us has an
insurance company taking the upside in
downside risk under the the last plan
that that passed the feltes plan the
state was taking the upside and downside
risk
thank you
um
you mentioned the statement you said
before you said that people want this
how many
uh
employers in the state have actually
come to the insurance department and
asked hey we really want this for our
employers and
out of those who came and asked how many
have not gone out in the private sector
and actually looked at doing it thank
you
so
i don't know i don't calculate uh
employers coming into church department
asking but that that's not typically how
it would work i attended the hearings
where people were in the halls holding
the you know we want this sign
i know that a lot of employers in new
hampshire self-fund this already you
know employers that have leave for
for
births or leave for short short leaves
or a comprehensive vacation and a sick
packages that build up and they
providing a product like this will allow
employers and the reason i believe a
group of players will adopt this is
because they'll be able to for those
that are self-insuring part of this risk
they may be using short-term disability
for part but they'll be able to get a
product that covers that
any further questions for the
commissioner
seeing none thank you very much for uh
spending your time with us this morning
though it felt like a little bit of an
inquisition it was so nice to be back
that i appreciate it i hope i i hope i
was helpful and i'm sorry for not being
at the
public hearing
thank you again
um
i would like
republicans have heard some new
information and i think we'd like to
ask for a 10-minute caucus
just to discuss
what we've heard today
so if we could
plan to be back in here between noon and
5 after and
i almost lost an hour there 11 and 5
after and we can
pick up again where we left off
thank you very much
let's pick it up
all right is everybody ready to go
i'm gonna call a uh executive session
back
in order thank you very much uh the
insurance commissioner for coming by
uh and providing that that detailed
information i apologize um that was
summoned away thank you guys for taking
care of things i'm gonna get back on our
agenda house bill 1165
repealing the granite state paid family
plan i call
representative um turcotte for a motion
representative proud i apologize
thank you mr chairman i move ought to
pass on this bill second the motion of
the floor is ought to pass on house bill
potions made by representative prout
seconded by representative turcotte
representative proud here recognized to
speak to your motion thank you mr
chairman
so what we've seen is that the
governor's plan with fmli has already
worked
private insurance companies are looking
to offer this type of fmli
this makes the state plan with its new
cost to fund fmli for state employees
unnecessary to achieve the original goal
i'm also concerned that the tax breaks
for this program along with the single
company getting the contract will create
an effective monopoly preventing any
other company from entering the market
in new hampshire
thank you thank you
representative adagent
thank you mr chairman um today i am
opposing hb 1165 the repeal of what sort
of can be called a granite state paid
family leave program
for the record i do not like this plan
that was passed as part of hb2 similar
to the way that i didn't like the
affordable care act in lieu of a public
option or universal healthcare
if i were to write a paid family leave
program it wouldn't look like this to
start it's not universal
an employee may only receive the
benefits
of paid family leave if their employer
preemptively signs up for the plan
there's no opportunity for an employee
to sign up and receive benefits under a
larger pool if their employer believes
that pfml is wrong
sure there are tax credits available for
employers to help convince them to sign
up
but just like we saw in burwell the
hobby lobby an employer can often have
undue influence over an employee's
choices
and why did i use scare quotes earlier
when talking about benefits well because
an employee can only count on 60 of
their normal income to be taken care of
when they need the benefits in 2020
cnbc noted
that 65 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck and have no room for savings
and according to forbes today that
number is closer to seven and ten
an employee who decides to use this plan
necessarily sets themselves up for
failure because they have to forego
forty percent of their regular income to
take advantage of a program that they
pay into
this may be possible for an
administrative assistant making about
fifty five thousand dollars a year but
for a state liquor store employee who's
already unfortunately making twelve
dollars an hour they would essentially
be expected to live on seven dollars an
hour again under a program that they are
already paying into
this program is financially exclusive
for lower income granite staters who end
up paying the taxes but cannot afford to
use the program
this plan in my opinion was regressive
poorly conceived and poorly executed
however
the above mentioned reasons aren't why
some folks want to get rid of this
program
the concern is that it essentially will
cost money well yes it does cost money
when you have a policy priority you
outline it you make a case for it and if
you have the public support you pay for
it
president roosevelt heard the same
opposition to the new deal by people who
said well we like these things we just
don't want to pay for them and during
his 1936 re-election campaign fdr
described these arguments as just turn
these things over to us
we will do all of them we will do more
of them we will do them better and most
important of all the doing of them will
not cost anybody anything
i do not believe the answer here is
repeal
just like i didn't think the answer to
the repeal the aca in 2017
even though i thought it was a weak
answer to the issue of health care in
america
it is my position that paid family leave
ought to be provided to folks with as
few hurdles technocratic non-solutions
and barriers as possible not to scrap a
weak plan and go back to nothing
we should make this plan better not
throw it away
as such i will be voting against this
repeal and will continue to work for not
access to paid family leave
not opportunity for paid family leave
but paid family leave for everyone and
anyone who needs it thank you mr
chairman
thank you
anyone else willing to speak
representative turcotte you recognize
thank you mr chairman
where to begin um
first of all there's so many unknowns in
this bill
um
to begin with i learned a couple more
today um we don't even know
what the net negative effect is going to
be on
tax
business taxes that are lost by
employers
who choose to opt into this plan
we don't know
what the cost of
to the taxpayers is going to be on the
close to 11 000 state employees that
this plan will cover at no cost to the
employees we've heard very low ball
estimates on that we know for
or
from previous attempts at this that the
uh the amount is going to be far far in
excess of what the bill had in it
back during the feltus i've mentioned
that before during the feltes plan we
had an individual who was a firefighter
who bought this type of insurance on his
own
that was had fewer benefits than this
and he was paying 60 a paycheck
so i believe when we get to
um the actual cost of this is going to
be so exorbitant that number one
private insurers uh private employers
are not going to be opting into this
plan it's just going to be too
too expensive for them so where are we
going to be we're going to have a plan
that exists with 11 000 state employees
who are being
who their
plans are being paid for by the
taxpayers and no private employer is
going to get into that
so what's going to happen
other public
workers throughout the state
are going to look at and say
the state employees are getting this
paid for why aren't we getting it paid
for
and they're going to demand from their
local towns their local
police unions firefighter unions
whatever
town employees are going to say we want
that and that additional cost is going
to end up on the backs of the
taxpayers so in effect what this is
going to end up being is a
taxpayer-funded fmli
plan
when it is being touted in the press as
a
private employer
option
we heard that
some i heard something new today
from the commissioner that people want
this well
who wants it i haven't heard of anybody
who wants it when asked the commissioner
really wasn't able to give any
anything but an
anecdotal we don't have any numbers on
that we don't know how many people want
this
we've heard that the you know other
states do this and it's it's in the
preamble of this bill itself the part
that came out of hb2
that it's a it's a way to attract and
retain workers well if that's the case
also we've got to look at the states
that have these plans now states like
new jersey
new york
illinois
california
those are the states that are for fmli
i i would
beg to differ that people are flocking
to those states in order to
become eligible from fmli in fact if if
you look at it those states are the
those with the highest net negative
migrations because they're fleeing those
states because of the high taxes and the
extent extensive social programs that
are there
i'm going to stop there i could go on
for a very long time going through this
part in hb2 and all the
inadequacies that are in there and why
this plan is is not something we need
here in new hampshire but i will leave
it at that i am in favor of the otopass
thank you
anyone else like to speak
on the motion on the floor
so i've been doing this long enough to
realize that
there's going to be 10 votes one way and
10 votes the other
and it's going to fall on me
to make the tying vote
and to say my phone was ringing off the
hook yesterday is an understatement as
to what i'm going to do
so i will give you my statement
i don't like
putting legislation in budget bills
it's gotten out of control over the last
couple years and it's not right
shouldn't be this shouldn't have been in
house bill 2.
i'm an insurance agent everyone knows
i've been doing that all my life
i think insurance
for better for worse
does it better than government when it
comes to anything
workers compensation
with a few problems seems to work all
right
employment securities with a few bumps
in the road at times seems to work all
right
i would rather see government or private
business do this rather than government
as a republican
i like the incentive
to
allow businesses to
offer this because i think every
business should offer some type of
disability medical however you want to
call it
giving them a discount off their
bet
is also something that's
advantageous
but how much
as a legislator i don't like to vote for
things when i don't know how much it's
going to cost
now finally i will applaud the governor
for coming up with an idea that was good
enough
that the private sector seems to want to
jump on it
so while that babe may not be the desire
of some
to have it through a private
company
i think it's the better way and the
governor
rung the bell
to allow that to happen
and i think
i have
again i am biased here but i have
tremendous faith in the insurance
department
that they will come up with something
that um will be at least palatable to
some
no one's going to get everything they
want
i will be supporting the um
the motion i had to pass
it doesn't make me happy
um
frustrates me that we couldn't do
something better
but you know it's not all up to this
committee and we can't solve every
problem
anyone else like to speak before we call
the role
the emotion on the floor is ought to
pass
it's been made and seconded discussion
has been had mr clerk please call the
role
seaworth
yes
avalani yes
callum yes
myself yes
love yes
warden yes
durkheim
yes
bro yes
boyd yes huff
yes
sullivan
no
susie
rudy no
cahill no
el chiller
no
bartlett no
to me no
bouchard
no
henchton no
yes
11 10.
i don't know if this was mentioned
before we do have a deadline i need the
blurbs both for and against
probably preferably by three o'clock
this afternoon so we can through the
process i do understand
that the closing is tomorrow technically
all bills have to be done with tomorrow
but heather needs chance to do her job
and to pass it along so
blurbs by three o'clock today if you can
please thank you
thank you representative
um
house bill
1210 relative to exemption for vaccine
mandates
recognize representative turcotte for a
motion
thank you mr chairman i move ought to
pass
on hb 12 10 as amended by
uh
2022-724-h or do we have to do the
amendment first yes
then i'd like to make a motion uh
propose amendment 20 20 20.
0724h
thank you emotions made and seconded by
representative avilani
you are now
recognized to speak on the
amendment that you're moving thank you
mr chair
um we
this was an amendment that came out of a
subcommittee
that five of us were involved with
you may remember we had several bills
that came before the committee talking
about different vaccine mandates and
different scenarios
what we did is we took three bills one
by tim representative lang won by
representative foster represented and
won by representative silber
and we took the good out of each of what
we
saw as the good out of each
and combine it into one bill and we
left out
those portions that were
we saw as not um
beneficial
um
we think that the the end product is uh
fairly good we we did not
make this apply to private employers as
most of you are welcome
as most you well know on this committee
our job we feel is not to get in in
between the employer and the employee
whenever possible
um
what this would
do is apply to any public employer or
any private employer that receives any
kind of public funding or
grants or anything like that it would
also apply to
post-secondary educational
institutions
other than that i think
everybody has seen the amendment
and i ask that you do support the
amendment thank you
thank you
representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman
um
this spills one of the more dangerous
bills that we've
dealt with um it's dangerous both on an
economic level and a medical level
economically
it puts at risk all of the medicare and
medicaid funding that goes to our
hospitals nursing homes
and other entities
and losing all of that funding
is a gigantic economic risk for the
state
um
for that reason alone we shouldn't be
doing it
but in addition it's a medical
risk
what this basically says is that anyone
who doesn't feel like getting vaccinated
against any
disease
can simply say i don't want to
and they then
don't get vaccinated
and we will see
infectious disease rates go up
here comes polio
here comes smallpox
here comes all the various diseases
measles this is not a covet bill
this is a bill against
all vaccines if you just don't want to
do it
it is
hugely dangerous
we should not do it i will be voting no
on ought to pass
thank you
thank you representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman
i want to respond to that because
everyone on the committee has been
receiving letters
making
the kinds of points that we just heard
from our fellow representative
i think the importance of this amendment
is
it resolves those issues
first of all well and it
it does it both in the same way
so if you read carefully the amendment
it does provide for the ability
to
ask for an exemption
based on the right of conscience the
right of conscience that's uh part of
our constitution and it says that the
employer
must
uh grant that exemption
but then what what happens next
does that force these
unvaccinated employees to remain at a
business that
by
federal mandates is required
not to allow them to do so no it does
not
because the the last sentence of section
two in the amendment says the employer
may
then work with the employment employee
to see if an agreement for reasonable
accommodation can be reached
if such an agreement can't be reached
or if reaching such an agreement is
expensive for example losing all your
medicare money
then the employer is under no obligation
to accommodate that employee
the employee can be dismissed problem
solved
similarly
under the current current
circumstances if there's an impasse if
an employer says
you know in order to remain employed
here you have to get this vaccine be it
covet or something else and an employee
says you know what no i i don't i
believe in
you know holistic medicine and only
taking things that are natural and i i
simply cannot take that vaccine
nobody can force that person to take the
vaccine you can fire them under under
the current situation
they will still remain on facts and
vaccinated and likewise once this bill
applies the employers may work with the
employee to find a situation where
they're
removed from facing the public or
removed from dealing with medically
sensitive patients or
with
medically sensitive fellow employees
or not they can say you know what the
nature of our business is that we can't
accommodate your request we've taken
your request
and we recognize that your right of
conscience
allows you
to be exempted but we cannot accommodate
you as employee
that's what's in this amendment that's
why i think this amendment is an
important change to the bill and it's an
amendment that addresses
uh
by and large
the concerns that we've received via
email in the last
few days or the last week so for that
reason i urge you
to support this amendment
thank you
president of cahill
thank you mr chairman uh i have two
concerns uh one being that
litigation that could ensue you know
because the employer the employee isn't
happy with the decision of the employer
and the other is
if this doesn't really do anything and
the employer is still free to terminate
what's the point of doing this bill
well i got everyone wants the answer
you're all welcome to answer the first
one i saw uh was turcotte then proud
then seaworth
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative cahill for the point
question i'll give you a prime example
of um
how this
is different
my company
that i work for became a
became
put under the federal contractor mandate
okay back last fall
now
our our company management
did not
want to force be forced to fire
20 percent of their pilot workforce
because they couldn't afford uh the
pilot workforce who had at first been
essential employees were now being
threatened with termination under the
vaccine
so what the company did
is they put out a statement to all of us
and they said
apply for the medical or the religious
exemption
well
if some of us being honest cannot
request an exemption of either those two
what do we do
the net effect of a religious exemption
and a right of conscience exemption is
the exact same
our company
was pushing
our pilots to apply for religious
exemptions
and saying don't worry we'll get it
because our company even though they
were under the threat of losing federal
money didn't want to lose their
essential employees
over a vaccine
issue so this
in that case
my company might not apply to this
within new hampshire you know i haven't
thought that through but that's an
example of
why the right of conscience has been
added in there
the right of conscience the net effect
of a right of conscience
or
a religious exemption in my mind
is the same
problem
thank you mr chairman
so
representative covered many points but
one of the things that this bill does
and that what it is new what it changes
as i see it is
is it gets companies and their associate
hr departments
out of the business as we have seen some
of them
charge into this business
of trying to test
an employee's
religiousness
how religious they are whether their
claim is valid
whether their religion
they're following the tenets of an
organized religion
and all the places that go
which for some companies has turned on
to almost a full-on inquisition and down
a road that
i don't
like people
the idea of people crying into
another person's private religious
beliefs especially in a regulated
environment like reasonable
accommodations and everything else
and that this bill short circuits that
aspect of it
the exemption shall be granted there's
no are you religious enough test
there's no
no judging of that by the
the company's hr department which i feel
they're
in a bad position to do that
and it goes straight to
okay
what can we do
to make sure the fact that you have an
exemption
doesn't mean you're a risk to
customers or other employees or
everywhere else and find an
accommodation that works
and skips that first part that has been
problematic
thank you
thank you um
what was just said the other thing i'll
respond to in terms of effect one of the
things we heard from deputy commissioner
lavers
uh he was asked about
during the pandemic
how many
workers were dismissed due to
refusal to take the cover 19 vaccine
and how many of those were eligible for
unemployment
and it was about 20 percent i think it
was a number
or it was a 20
uh
my recollection
15 to 20 individuals
were eligible for unemployment
in about 80 percent if i remember the
numbers and i'm probably not so
take that
[Music]
a reason
for
unemployment being
granted to the dismissed individual was
that they had submitted and been awarded
an exemption to the vaccination
so that's
this goes in terms of the effect i think
that that would be a real effect and
it's an effect for that situation that
representative turcotte described
where you have an individual
that for
reasons important to them
but not a a reason that's religious
simply will not
take that vaccination
it it treats them on an equal footage to
those that have a religious exemption
that right now through the processes we
go for go through are recognized and
makes them equally eligible for
unemployment
on both cases so
i do think there is a real effect
and
like my fellow representatives i see
that effect as a net positive
president of mandal
thank you mr chairman uh i agree with
the statement that representative
sullivan made at the beginning and i
think that's the most important aspect
that we gotten to lose even as we
thought think and talk about covet i
would only add this though that i was
listening carefully to representative
prout and he
did
indicate that a benefit as he sought of
this bill would be to get
companies
out of the business of being involved in
religious tests and their
assessments and so forth and as that may
be true one unfortunate aspect is that
it would get the government more into
the business of businesses in ways that
it seems to me
might be
sub-optimal
i didn't want to be the chairman of a
committee that was responsible for
a bill coming out of the house that
would take away 200 million dollars
worth of funding for medicare and
medicaid
um so i dug into this thing like i
probably never dug into a bill before
and
it is
i mean i i rep i i
congratulated representative turcotte
for threading the needle the way he did
if you really look at the amendment
we are
the the amendment supports not getting
involved
necessarily between
the hospitals or anyone receiving that
and their contracts
with the federal government because it
says you will
you will accept the
the um
exemption
but you may or may not
choose to
keep them on based on that
now
representative cahill asks questions so
why bother well it helps in a number of
reasons
the employer
can make a decision
a good employee
very valuable we don't want to lose
employees we can put them somewhere else
or do something else that may not
violate our contracts
or we will not
they sell the same position they were in
before if they want to fire someone or
not but it also gives them a a mechanism
that they may
be able to make some accommodations
if that employee
is then fired because the
the
employer feels that there it is a
violation between their contract
uh with medicare and medicaid they can
go to unemployment securities
for benefits unemployment securities
will look at that and say
whether or not the employer
was consistent or arbitrary
so they gave john brian and i
the exemption and put it somewhere else
but not let in in
lino
well no that's not consistent the
department will then make that decision
whether or not they will get the
benefits or not which is what they have
been doing now which is why only a
certain percentage of them have received
the benefits
so
i
i respectfully disagree with
representative sullivan i don't think
any of us that are going to support this
today
are foolish enough to think that we're
going to take away 200 million dollars
worth of funds
to hospitals
and
nursing homes to put them all out of
business
this is simply not the case now is it
narrowly written and would a lawyer have
to look at it sure
i'll admit to that
but
we did our best to keep this
ourselves and this bill out of the
relationship between
the medical institution and where they
get their funds
now maybe it's not as clear to some
because it took trust me it took me a
little while to figure it out too
but
i i can't speak for my fellow colleagues
but i
will not vote for a bill that takes away
that kind of funds and i
do not believe this does
seeing no other hands
the motion for the amendment has been
made second there's been discussion mr
clark he's called the role seaworth yes
avalani
callum yes myself yes
love yes
warden yes
yes
pro yes boyd yes puff
sullivan
no susie
rudy no
cahill no
outshiller
bartlett no
toomey
bouchard no hedgeton no minimal no
infantine yes
11 10.
13 37 is next
yeah
open for further uh
action thank you mr chairman i i move uh
house bill 10 as amended out to pass
motion has been made out to pass with
amendment seconded by representative
seaworth
you're well recognized to speak to your
motion
the amendment is the new bill so i think
we've gone over that
quite enough already thank you
the only last comment i'd like to make
is um initially i had asked the hospital
association to provide me with an
amendment
that would have taken a certain group of
people out of the um
not being applied to the bill
and
it was shown to me otherwise that
it was not necessary but that amendment
is available if someone chooses to if it
does pass the house to go on to the
senate
seeing no other
individuals willing to wanting to speak
motion on the floor has ought to pass
the amendment it has been made and
seconded discussion has been had mr
clerk please call the role seaworth yes
avaloni yes callum yes myself yes
love yes warden yes
turcotte
yes
yes floyd yes
sullivan no
susie no rudy no cale no
i'll chiller no
bartlett no toomey
bouchard no extent now
mandeville no
infantine yes
11 10.
next bill up for discussion is house
bill 1337
relative to the duration of unemployment
benefits
i recognize representative turcotte for
a motion
thank you mr chairman i'd move amendment
excuse my amendment 2022-0
seven three two h
zero seven three two eight
okay
motions made and seconded
by representative avalaning
you're recognized to speak to your
motion
thank you mr chairman um the
amendment before you were places in its
entirety uh original bill 1337 although
the
the the framework of the bill remains uh
as it was what i'm going to do is go
over some of the changes just so
everybody understands
in the original bill
we had a
the maximum
number of weeks
for unemployment had been
reduced to 20.
under the new bill
it remains at 26.
it still has the same effect and that is
when the unemployment rate is high the
number of weeks of unemployment
compensation is high
when the unemployment unemployment rate
is low
those number of weeks are reduced
so
under the new bill or under the
amendment i should say
it goes from 26 weeks maximum
down to
12. 16. the original bill we put forward
was 12 weeks
we had lots of input from the business
associations and different groups and i
i want to thank upfront deputy
commissioner lavers he's been very very
helpful with supplying data and some and
different things on this
um
he um
he volunteered some information a couple
weeks ago on uh
claims and the length of unemployment
going back in the 2018-2019 version and
that was very helpful and after looking
at that i
believe that the 16 weeks was a a better
number on the lower end of the scale and
that sixteen weeks is any time
the unemployment rate is below three
percent like it is today
we did receive input from the
contractors association on the seasonal
uh seasonal workers
uh that that was also a one of the
reasons that we changed at the bottom
from 12 weeks to 16. i know it's not
quite what they were looking for
but uh in all honesty any time that the
unemployment rate is below 3
anybody who's going to be employed for
four or five months over the winter
months in this especially in this type
of environment there's obviously
jobs out there we all hear the job
offerings on the radio we see them
online we see them as we drive down the
road so although that wasn't quite what
they were looking for it is a four week
improvement the other thing i did on
that is originally we pegged the
benchmark
on the third quarter of each year
in this in the amendment i've changed it
to the fourth quarter and the reason for
that was also for this seasonal
although it's probably not going to make
a huge difference
the unemployment rate will necessarily
be a little bit higher in those months
because of the seasonal workers
in the very first uh actually line five
um we had had uh some conversations and
some uh concerns about
you know what would happen again in in
the case of a covert nine situation 19
situation like we just had or the
economic
downturn we had in 2008 time frame
deputy commissioner lavers laver said
that he didn't really feel that was a
huge issue only because the feds in both
cases have stepped in
at times when uh
the unemployment rate has gone very you
know necessarily high
even though he
he i believe he feels comfortable with
that i actually added in in line five a
uh three words not withstanding
rsa445 and what that does
is it puts this language
or it attaches to this language a state
of emergency so if we were ever in a
declared state of emergency again
uh the the governor would have the
ability to alter
uh this uh
this pair uh
the new uh
indexing of the unemployment
uh the very last thing i changed in it
uh was the effective day originally it
was 60. i changed it to 120 and that was
simply to give all parties involved
employers employees
the department and
everybody else the ability to
you know get to get their ducks in a row
before it actually became effective
and i think i have covered everything on
that thank you mr chairman
thank you
rosanna sullivan
thank you mr chairman
um
this amendment i believe
makes the original bill um a little less
bad
um i will therefore support the
amendment
um
the uh the problem with this is
that
um the unemployment rate certainly does
affect the ability of people to find
employment
but it's not the only thing that if that
affects
people's ability to find employment
there are some people when they lose a
job because of family circumstances
because of physical frailty
because of age
or other factors they may find that they
have a difficult time
finding
replacement employment
therefore access to the full 26 weeks
is important
we heard testimony that
it is rare for people to use the full 26
weeks
most people because they're required to
look for work are able to find it
the requirement to seek work
works
so essentially
this bill is unnecessary because we
already have a population that gets back
to work when they lose their job
but we also have an employment security
system
that provides for the people who can't
find work for various reasons
and no matter what the reason is they
can access those 26 weeks
if
there are circumstances that make it
impossible for them to find work sooner
so
i i don't like the amendment but i like
it better than the original bill
therefore i will support the amendment i
will not support the ought to pass thank
you
was gonna ask a question buddy do you
have another comment represent
yes
thank you mr chairman
in response to uh
representatives uh points
uh
again the
the data that was provided was very
informative um
i'll just kind of read it off from what
i have
those and again this is from 2018 2019
which very similar situation i guess to
where we are now
but
uh pretty much 50 percent of people
used unemployment
for less than 10 weeks that's an
astounding number
and up to between the bracket that i was
given between 15 and 19 a full 75
percent
use between 15 and 19 weeks or less 75
then there's a spattering
of percentages very very low single
digits between 20 21 22 23 24 25 until
you get to 26 and at 26
there's a 16
number now
we can all
make assumptions as to what how that 16
percent is made up of
[Music]
i don't like i don't think we should be
writing laws
for the
minority of the
uh
people affected by this i believe the 16
at the full 20 26 weeks there may be
some of those in that that are there for
other reasons than simply they can't
find work
i don't know what the percentage is
but again we shouldn't be writing laws
for that i agree that we have a great
system in new hampshire already the
deputy commissioner lavers has made that
statement i'm totally in agreement with
them
the bottom line on this
is by going to an indexing rate
not only does it incentivize people to
get back to work as soon as possible
even though our new hampshire people do
a pretty darn good job already but the
other
the other thing and this has been found
in every other state it's tried again i
think i talked about florida as the
the
gold star state who
put this indexing into their laws but
that is that the uninsurance rate
unemployment insurance rates that the
businesses pay will also go down it's
going to go down immediately no it'll
probably take a time for for everything
to kind of
work its way in but uh certainly
uninsurance employment rates aren't
going to go up for businesses so again i
i would hope everybody support this
thank you
we have we take a question
do you know how many years this has been
a place in massachusetts and if whether
or not they have made any changes uh to
their original because of maybe
unintended consequences
no
i don't i do not know the answer to that
but you know you know how long it's been
in places of massachusetts
if you gave me time to actually research
and get into my paperwork
probably find it but you got about two
minutes while we will do the roll
are there any individuals willing
likings like to speak on the amendment
the amendment on the floor is uh
2022-0732h
it's been moved seconded and discussion
has been had
mr clerk would you please call the roll
seaworth
yes
avalani
callum yes
myself yes love yes
warden
yes
sullivan yes
susie yes
rudy yes
cahill yes
el chiller
yes
bartlett yes
toomey
bouchard yes
edgeton
mandeville yes
in the time yes
twenty to one
the motion has passed the bill is now
open for further action representative
turcotte
yes i move uh house bill 1337 as amended
uh
octopus
has been made ought to pass with
amendment by representative turcotte
seconded by representative avaloni
they were recognized to speak to your
motion thank you mr chairman uh
similar to the last bill we talked about
this one uh
the amendment replaces the entire bill
so we've had i think had the discussion
that we need to on that thank you
governor sullivan
i would simply like to uh say that
i believe we do make legislation for the
the minority for the 16 percent that
take the full 26 weeks that's how we
take care of people it doesn't happen
often the majority of people don't use
the 26 weeks
not anywhere close to it
but
this is definitely a case of
if it ain't broke don't fix it
so uh i say leave it alone we've got a
good system thank you
um
yeah no it's not that i don't know your
name i just if you were going to speak a
second time i'd i have an individual
willing to speak the first time as well
so i'd like to do that if i could
represent you were recognized
thank you mr chairman um i believe uh
representative sullivan did a good job
speaking about the specific mechanical
issues associated with the bill
my issue is more philosophical
this bill seeks to drastically slash the
social social safety net after a year of
complaints that unemployment makes it so
nobody wants to work anymore
in june of 2021 the argument was simple
a 300 a week unemployment benefit at a
time when you're lucky to only have that
as your rent was so lucrative and
succulent that people chose to stay home
instead of going to these wonderful
well-paying jobs that we had open
that belief was tested in july of 2021
when the video administration ended the
federal unemployment enhancement this
was beautiful because finally we would
get everybody back to work the following
jobs report was atrocious because as it
turned out randomly slashing
unemployment benefits did not fix all
our problems
reading from cnbc
ending federal unemployment benefits had
little impact on jobs and fueled two
billion dollar spending cut study fines
if that's not your taste the economic
policy institute
cutting unemployment insurance benefits
did not boost job growth the july
unemployment and unemployment data
released friday by the bureau of labor
statistics showed that strong job growth
reported earlier this month in the
national jobs data was widespread
throughout the country and notably the
states that chose not to cut pandemic
employment insurance benefits
that have expired on average
had
i'm reading that wrong hold on
um
reading from
this is another epi piece states that
cut employment benefits saw limited
impact on job growth states that ended
enhanced federal unemployment benefits
early have so far seen about the same
job growth as states that continued
offering the pandemic related extra aid
according to a wall street journal
analysis of the economists
if the question is is ui the key thing
that's holding us back the labor market
recovery the answer is no definitely not
based on the available data said peter
ganon a university of chicago economist
referring to unemployment insurance
how about business insider the research
keeps coming out about how governors
hurt their states when they cut off
employment benefits early
reading from the article however there's
one thing that increasingly hasn't
happened
research has continually found that
cutting off the benefits early had
little difference on job growth in
employment the latest analysis comes
from the wall street journal which found
that there were roughly similar job
growth in states that did and did not
opt out of benefits that aligns with
other early research on the impact of
benefits
cnbc reports that analysis from payroll
firms home base and ukg found both that
employment didn't go up in states that
were cutting off benefits
in fact the home base analysis found
that employment declined in states
opting out of the federal benefits while
it went up in states that chose to
retain benefits in june indeed's hiring
lab found that the job searches in
states ending benefits were below
april's baseline
so here we are in new hampshire looking
at the same philosophical idea that the
federal government did in 2021 about to
do the same thing and expecting
different results
if you want to increase workforce
participation you raise the minimum wage
participation you stop attacking the
trade union movement if you want to
increase workforce participation you
create more time protections for service
employees you crack down on wage theft
all of these things will increase
workforce participation but blaming an
already tattered social safety net for
doing the good job that it was designed
to do is not a way to fill the vacant
jobs we have open i enthusiastically
oppose the otp motion for this bill and
hope the committee overturns it so a
different motion can be made thank you
mr chairman welcome representative
cahill
thank you mr chairman uh i'm going to be
brief
and i'll just quote what i believe mr
labors told us when we originally
discussed the bill that our weekly
benefit amount is enough incentive to
get people back to work
thank you mr chairman uh just addressing
a couple of points that i made let's
start with the the 16 percent um that
used utilized in uh 2018 and 2019 the
full 26
weeks the point when i made that i was
trying to be subtle about it but at it
from
19 weeks to 25 weeks
there's almost zero utilization in other
words almost nobody uses that those
number of weeks
yet when you get to 26
weeks
all of a sudden that number jumps to 16
percent
i have my thoughts on why that happens
some may have other reasons uh the 300 a
month let's let's talk about that that's
a good point to bring up last spring
uh the governor
when asked
decided he was going to retain and keep
the 300 dollar a week
money coming from
the federal government
he quickly reversed that less than a
couple weeks later and the reason he
he
took that back is because businesses
complained to him said we need to get
our workers back
and he quickly
did a u-turn on his his thoughts on that
so yes in fact the three hundred dollars
a week twelve hundred dollars a month
was
enough on top of all the other benefits
that were being given
to keep people out of the workforce and
the businesses made that point crystal
clear to the governor and he reversed
his uh
his original
thought thank you
representative would you take a question
i will not
okay
um then i will just make a comment um i
believe i laid out pretty clearly that
slashing the 300 week benefit did not
have a discernible impact on getting
people back to work and filling jobs
um just because
businesses thought that it would and
then it didn't that i don't think that's
a justification
thank you representative rudy then
mandeville
thank you mr chairman
um
before the pandemic
i was asked to help some people find a
job
most of them elderly people who had been
in a job for a long time
um
and they
for one reason or another lost a job
plant closing or whatever
so the church asked me to get involved
with some of these people writing
resumes for them
sending out letters helping them find a
job trying to teach them new skills
basic skills
um
especially people in the end of their
work working lives
if they lose their job
it's pretty hard to retrain and find
another job
i had maybe eight or ten people that
went over to 26 weeks he's a good
working people
fairly intelligent
but just needed a different
different job classification they needed
retraining
26 weeks doesn't even always cut it so
and that was before the pandemic
now covert comes along and we have
businesses closing
you take a person working at one job for
30 years
that's all he knows it's all she knows
they lose their job
what happens to them
they know nothing else it takes them a
while to find somewhere to go
thank you
very much
thank you mr chairman
i
listened to
representative turcotte's uh statistics
and i was interested in them too and as
he acknowledges that there's some degree
of speculation
on both sides of the coin i imagine
relative to the 16
versus the lesser
uh percentage numbers for
the periods of time below 26 weeks
to me it signifies as representative
broody is just implicitly referred to
that there are circumstances that are
unique to particular people which i
think our current system has been
intended to and does
address by way of
discouraging
staying out of the workforce but
providing for those with particular
needs and the question is
what the particularities are
the fact of looking at
at 26 weeks and comparing it to 19 or 17
actually just
heightens
the
context
for the 26 weeks as it might bear on
matters of particular concern either to
the difficulties of retraining
the circumstances of a particular
person's
skills location
experience etc and it seems to me the
the idea of indexing
this to unemployment
is
takes little if anything into account
relative to the peculiarities of
the length of time between
um
26 weeks and and a lesser amount of time
so i i oppose this and by the way if it
if it doesn't seem presumptuous i would
say as
the youngest or newest member of the
group that i think it's incumbent upon
us in my opinion to approve of of uh
amendments that
even for bills we oppose we think
improves them and therefore i was
pleased to vote in favor of the
amendment but against the bill thank you
mr chairman
the uh a member of this committee serves
on the employment securities advisory
board i am currently that person before
i believe representative sullivan was uh
prior no representative goalie
representative susan
and and uh they meet and they go over
these things and they make
recommendations um
the advisory board was against three
bills that came in front of us this year
and we've killed those three
uh they really didn't have a position on
this um on this
but i did send all of you this report
and all these graphs and it's very
telling
the the two biggest areas where people
left new hampshire employment since the
pandemic
are notably folks 60 to 64. which i
think we can all assume you know okay
it's time maybe we're going to take an
early retirement don't want to deal with
this re reassess life because of this
terrible tragedy that has uh been in
front of this country and the world
the one that was most notable was
individuals from 25 to 29
left the workforce
why
was it because of the benefits that were
given
you know we can all make our own
assumptions as to what's going on
understand employment securities is paid
for by the employers
okay
and most employers
approve of it
um because
uh you know because they are there take
you know paying for it they it's a
combination of the right thing to do
it's a combination of uh it's better for
society i mean this is one of those real
social type things that employers pay
to help people get back up to get moving
and and else
so it's kind of incumbent on us we want
to make sure we have done a lot of
things in this committee to make sure
people are getting back to work
any of you who served here years ago
recall that it used to be you took the
16 weeks off in the winter time for
seasonal you don't have to work you have
to look for a job
that we changed that now they do and
people are looking for jobs
in the winter months if they're an
operator they find work as a machinist
or something moving a a
forklift or whatever in a business they
find those things to do and that's
require requirement that we made in this
state
and it's been actually
pretty good for some people i know
people have said yeah i found a better
job working on this working in the
winter i found a job i liked better
so
it's always okay to
try to
look about making the mouse trap better
one major issue
that came up in front of us years ago
had to do with workers compensation if
you all remember this i spent a
tremendous amount of time on this
we had a
sentence in the law that was
being misinterpreted that
hospitals or medical facilities could
charge whatever they wanted and it had
to be paid by the insurance carriers we
got to change that around
i was okay at the last minute
another republican
came in on the house floor
dan and carol dan uh
maguire came in
and put an amendment through
and put a big monkey wrench in the thing
i and i didn't like it because i was
fearful
that his change
was going to cause a
train load of people to be going to the
department of labor and arguing it
and guess who was wrong
i was
everyone figured it out
they made their own deals between the
medical and the workers comp
so the government didn't have to
but i was fearful i said no you guys are
wrong you're taking all my hard work and
all this committee's work and you're
doing this on the house floor and it's
going to be a catastrophe and i was
wrong and it's been probably one of the
better things and what's happened to our
workers comp rates in the last 10 years
we've gone down
so yes sometimes we're fearful of this
i'll be the first one to tell you if
this doesn't work i'm going to
employment securities advisory board and
i'll come back to this legislature and
say no this isn't working here it
doesn't work in new hampshire we're
going to change it
it's worth seeing if this
makes the system better
and that's why i'll be supporting it
seeing no other hands
appreciate the
honest
uh
passionate conversation
bill has been um
motions ought to pass with amendment
emotions are made seconded discussions
been had if you're in favor of the bill
you'll be saying uh yes if you're again
she'll be saying no mr clerk please call
the roll
seaworth yes avalani yeah callum yes
myself yes love yes warden yes
yes pro yes boyd yes puff yes
sullivan no
susie
rudy nope cahill no
el chiller
no
bartlett no toomey no bouchard
hedges no
mandible no
infantine yes
11 10.
last bill in front of us
house bill 1529 fn respective employees
and volunteers for public libraries
obtaining a background check
just waiting for a second for the clerk
please
um
i recognize representative love for a
motion
thank you mr chair i uh i make a motion
to to find this itl
uh
okay the motion has been made to itl
it's been seconded by representative
seaworth you may speak to your motion
thank you mr chair
thank you mr chair and committee members
when i introduced house bill 1529 i
spoke of one instance where information
that was given to me by a couple
constituents turned out to be erroneous
in the second instance emotion got the
best of me not only five years ago but
when i read the information but in
testimony also i was mistaken
i apologize for any hurt or ill feelings
that i i have caused anyone here on the
live stream or anywhere for that matter
by that testimony
as as uh house bill 1529 nobody's done a
more done more harm to well-intentioned
legislation than i have here
i asked the committee vote to find house
bill 1529 itl my hope here is that we
could find a a bipartisan consensus and
on the idea and hopefully bring a bill
forward in the future
thank you
motion uh has been made in second
your comments
thank you
any other comments any other
any individuals wishing to speak
representative soucy
thank you mr chairman i just want to
applaud my colleague i think it takes a
lot of courage to do something like that
and i agree with them that uh this bill
itl is the right motion so thank you and
thank you for your apology
yes thank you very much representative
love
for your comments and your motion
seeing no other
comments
individuals willing to speak the motion
on the floor is inexpedient to legislate
it has been made and seconded and
comments have been had if you are in
favor of the inexpensive legislate you
will say yes if you are against you will
say no representative excuse me mr clark
would you please call the roll seaworth
yes
avalani
callum yes
myself yes
love yes gordon yes turcotte
yes pro yes
void yes
sullivan
yes
susie yes
rudy yes
cahill yes
el chiller
yes
bartlett yes
to me bouchard yes edgerton yes
medieval yes
yes
21-0
representative sullivan consent
acceptable
any objection
seeing none uh
this will
be on the consent agenda
that concludes all of the bills in front
of the labor committee for this session
the calendar we have bills on tomorrow
it was asked of me
why we didn't have more bills on the
agenda i had no involvement with that
the speaker and the speaker's office and
the clerk make a decision on what's
going on
thank you very much for getting me the
information on who will be speaking on
on your on behalf of your
either majority or minority reports
if you would get to me
by three o'clock today your blurbs
and um let me know next week who will be
speaking as brian and i representative
sullivan and i communicate
as to who will be speaking so we notify
the clerk as well
to to be speaking on the floor
are there any
questions or com
either questions of me or the comments
representative proud or representative
abalone
i'm sorry i can't see all these big guys
in front of me thank you mr chairman uh
senate bills do we have uh a few coming
over or are we done
um i don't believe we are done um
representative and i have looked at them
periodically there were originally seven
bills which i felt might come to us
i have not checked to see whether any of
those have come over i would expect
probably three to five pieces of
legislation coming over
i will try to
only have a if we can get
a house session of one day with three or
four bills
to try to not have you you know come up
obviously with your jobs and other
obligations to come up once
and we'll see how that goes
thank you
nervous and sullivan
all right thank you everyone be well
foreign
you